APD's sources say the suspect is Jesse
Bruce
Pinkman a local man who was a student of
lights before joining him in the drug
trade the fans like Ravid like obsession
with the series I think is the reason
why you guys had to be so tricky cuz
y'all we're really tricky with this
whole really tricky you know so how was
it keeping under wraps did you like have
to wear masks in Albuquerque so people
didn't see you um to be honest when
we're going to set from base camp to set
they did have us wear these like big
sort of like Star Wars kind of cloaks
you know just covering our entire bodies
which felt hilarious
but you know what on the day-to-day you
know in the weekends I just kind of went
out and people would come up to me and
you know ask for photos or autographs or
whatever and asked why I was there and I
would just lie to them and it was fine
no one's no one really second-guessed it
speaking of the fans I feel that they
are they still coming up to you asking
you to call them [ __ ] is this still a
thing cuz I remember you've talked about
this a lot yeah big solo Heil Hitler
[ __ ] where's my money [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
Gatorade me [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah I
honestly not as much this movie may
spark that a little more but yeah it's
either them asking me to call them [ __ ]
you're asking me to call their wife a
[ __ ] or their mother a [ __ ] or
grandmother a [ __ ]
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there you
do it so well though so I can't really
be mad at them again the series is
something everybody loves do you have a
favorite moment from the series that you
like go back to and say okay this is
this is what I love man I mean to be
honest it all goes back to the pilot you
know I just I've seen the pilot you know
probably more than you know any other
episode of the series and and when we
all first watched the pilot together on
the Sony lot we just our jaws are on the
floor
we knew we were part of something but
something special before but once we saw
it all pieced together with just
everything oh my god this is gonna this
is gonna change everything
you ready
[Applause]
[Music]